are you afraid and if so what are you
afraid of
absolutely what are you scared of you
know I've been told not to talk about it
because once they know when they see
this and they know that's what they'll
go after so I am you know petrified I've
read you know in other places that you
you're afraid of physical abuse of any
kind is that something that you think
about that that you worry about it's not
something that I think about it kind of
blocked it out but it's definitely
something that I'm terrified of yes do
you think you'll be confronted by people
who saw you on the show maybe have a
perception of you feel they can perhaps
how are you preparing mentally for any
of that you can't and I never used the
word tip but they can do girl are you
are you a religious person do you pray
do you I'm Catholic I I've said that
many times how did a nice Catholic girl
from Pittsburgh just end up here yeah
does that help you through this part of
this journey yes absolutely and I mean
what what do you pray for what do you
what do you seek that can that can make
this easier for you well guidance you
know doing the right thing but you don't
know who do I turn to who do I you know
whatever
[Music]